[Music]
on this tuesday night the deadly
consequences of canada's
record-shattering heat
check on your co-workers to check on
other family members dozens of sudden
deaths in bc
the connection to climate change and how
canada is not adapting fast enough to
the extreme heat
new evidence residents of that florida
condo were warned about its poor
condition
two months before it collapsed like a
bomb looks like a bomb
canada's coveted 19 deaths why there may
be thousands more
than have been officially recorded and
to
preserve and protect a billionaire's
donation to help care for bc's coastal
ecosystems
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with the record-shattering
heatwave in the west
tonight the stifling temperatures are
shifting eastward into alberta and
saskatchewan
and in bc where the majority of people
don't have air conditioning
the toll the heat is taking is becoming
clear the cities of vancouver burnaby
and surrey
say at least 125 people have died
suddenly since last friday
police believe many of the deaths are
linked to the heat and many of those who
died
were seniors in vancouver alone today
20 sudden deaths have been reported
there are usually
between three to four reports of sudden
deaths per day
we are in the midst of the hottest week
british columbians have ever experienced
and there are consequences to that
disastrous consequences for families and
for communities
how we get through this extraordinary
time is by hanging together
checking up on those people we know
might be at risk
and this afternoon the village of linton
bc hit a high of 49 degrees the third
day in a row it has broken the record
for the hottest place in canada
according to environment canada
59 areas in bc set new temperature
records yesterday yesterday
in vancouver the average temperature for
this day is 20 degrees
at noon pacific today it was 31 degrees
in cologne it was 39
and in edmonton it was 37 warnings
connected to this heat wave stretch as
far east
as manitoba if this were a one-off heat
wave we'd be grateful when it passes
and moves on but the thing is it's not
just about single day extremes
a new federal report says extreme heat
events will become much more common
if we don't act fast to reduce
greenhouse gas emissions
the report shows what could happen in
six canadian cities
in the high emissions scenario montreal
could see as many as
75 extreme heat days per year that could
be cut to
20 days per year if emissions are
reduced
we'll have more on that in a moment but
we begin with the deadly effects the
extreme heat is having
right now heather urix west has our top
story
in bc the historic heat wave has already
been linked to a staggering loss of
life according to rcmp a resident at
this
home died monday night i went into the
house
and i checked her at that time and
she was not breathing she did not have
a pulse and was slumped over
unresponsive
just one of dozens of sudden deaths
believed to be related to the heat
first responders across the province's
lower mainland
are overwhelmed with this heat and these
extreme temperatures we're seeing higher
than ever call volumes from what i am
told
it is the busiest we have ever seen the
city of vancouver and vancouver fire
rescue services
bc remained under a heat warning tuesday
with parts of the okanagan reaching
daytime highs
in the mid 40's
get a whole bunch of fans and just wait
it out
starting wednesday camp fires across bc
will be banned
there are already 25 active wildfires
across the province including one north
of kamloops lake that is now burning out
of control
and it's still only june here in calgary
not only is the city under
a heat advisory with temperatures rising
to the high
30s poor air quality is expected in the
evenings as well
as this heat dome traps pollutants down
below
air quality is a concern across most of
bc and alberta
health officials urging residents to be
careful when working or
exercising outside check on your
co-workers to check on other family
members
offer them water double check how
they're feeling whether they need to be
taking a break or not
the heat also stretching mountain rescue
resources
in kananaskis alberta search crews were
called out 21 times over the weekend
responding to calls for water rescues
heat stroke and
other injuries the heat has health
rescue and fire officials
all on edge as western canada's
punishing weather
stretches on heather urex west global
news
calgary not only are many buildings in
the west not equipped with air
conditioning
other infrastructure is not designed to
withstand
persistent extreme heat in metro
vancouver it's been so hot some
sidewalks have started to buckle
it's happened in downtown vancouver and
in nearby port coquitlam
and in portland oregon where it's
usually about 24 degrees right now the
heat soared
into the 40s this week causing streetcar
power cables to melt and service
to be suspended experts say what's
happening is part of a pattern
and it's just a taste of what's to come
eric sorenson reports
there is nothing new about a heat dome
but what is trapping heat in western
canada is bigger
hotter and longer lasting than any heat
occurrence before
more than a weather system believes
scientists part of a pattern of
increasingly extreme events
that can be attributed to global warming
climate change didn't create
heat domes it just makes them worse
there's an element of it that is just
different
and i think it is probably the human
component the human component is pumping
carbon into the atmosphere
holding in the heat northern latitudes
warm faster
and large land masses warm faster canada
represents both
and we will feel it in cities where
roughly 80 percent of canadians live
we are going to see more and more of
these hot days
in all parts of canada from 1976 to 2005
most canadian cities had just a handful
of very hot days
above 30 degrees celsius by mid-century
that will change dramatically
calgary will go from 5 to 32 very hot
days
toronto from 11 to 55 and it's a similar
story
across the interior of the country it'll
be less dramatic on the coasts but
coastal regions can expect more warm
days above 25 celsius
st john's newfoundland will go from
eight warm days per year to over 32
by mid-century vancouver from 18 to 72
warm days wherever you live more warm
days
and more hot days are coming as roads
buckle from hot weather in places where
it's never happened before
experts say we must plan our communities
to withstand the heat
the floods and other extremes that are
coming it's very important
that we rebuild our infrastructure our
societies in a way that they're adapted
to the
changing climate and so we become
resilient and hence less
impacted by the changing climate in the
decades to come canada's future also
includes a warming arctic
northern communities accustomed to
freezing winters will by 2050
see far fewer days below -30 and a
winter that's not as cold
will only contribute to summers that are
more and more hot
eric sorensen global news toronto
we are adapted to deal with the cold in
canada but not prepared to deal with the
impact of long bouts of extreme heat and
a timely report from the federal
government spells that out
it was released yesterday it found large
gaps remain in our preparedness for
climate change
individuals governments and private
companies need to act fast
to adapt david aiken explains
the call to action is clear the
challenge is that we're not acting right
now
like we're in an emergency the
government the federal government's
approach has been quite tentative
and the federal government's own
scientists say it is
vital to accelerate plans to help
provinces cities and towns
deal with more frequent extreme weather
events
that could involve everything from
retrofitting homes and mild climates
with air conditioning
to building canals and dikes to deal
with rising water levels in coastal
communities
such a strategy will also require some
heavy lifting
from provincial governments as well
upper levels of government are going to
have to provide
municipalities and individuals and
businesses with the supports to invest
in strengthening our infrastructure to
adapt to a changing climate
the 750-page federal government report
says
canada is simply not ready for so many
extreme weather events that work needs
to take place faster than ever because
this is an emergency we're in a crisis
and we need the government to act like
one problem flagged in the federal
report the country's roads
sewers airports hydro lines and so on
were designed and built by engineers
who assumed that they would exist in
quote a steady state
northern climate we are facing a climate
emergency i mean
who would have thought words like heat
dome polar vortex would be part of our
vocabulary
canada's environment minister says a
national adaptation strategy
is in the works we have to be thinking
about how we adapt to some of the uh
the impacts of climate change that we're
seeing today and that are already baked
in to what we're going to see over the
next number of years
the federal government and climate
campaigners will argue
spending on climate adaptation measures
can pay for itself
in the long run consider this in the
14-year period from 1983 to 2007
insurance losses related to extreme
weather events
totaled about 400 million dollars a year
but in the 10-year period from 2008 to
2018
insurance losses totaled 1.9
billion dollars a year the claims for
the fort mcmurray wildfire of 2016 alone
totaled 3.9 billion dollars and those
costs will only climb in the future the
report says
without much more investment to deal
with the effects
of climate change david aiken global
news
ottawa the commander of the royal
canadian navy vice admiral craig baines
has been given a chance to redeem
himself
baines faced heavy criticism for playing
golf with former chief of the defense
staff general jonathan vance last month
vance is under military police
investigation for sexual misconduct with
female subordinates
at the time baines called that golf game
a public display of support
he later apologized for that remark and
after two weeks of deliberating the
acting top soldier lieutenant general
wayne ayer issued a memo to the military
saying baines admitted his error in
judgment
error writes knowing his moral authority
has diminished he is determined to
regain the trust and confidence of all
through humility in showing us how to
learn reconcile error
and become a better leader calls for
accountability are growing louder in
florida there are no signs of more
survivors at that collapsed condo and
parts of the crumbled building are too
dangerous for rescue crews to enter
the county fire chief says 3 million
pounds of concrete
have already been removed from the site
residents were warned the building
needed millions of dollars in structural
repairs
and new images show just how badly those
repairs were needed
jackson proskow reports from surfside
florida
six days in and there's no sign of a
miracle
families are stuck in purgatory waiting
for answers that still haven't come
nobody's giving up hope here nobody's
stopping
the work goes on full force
these are real people these are you know
my neighbors and
montreal-born trauma surgeon dr howard
lieberman has been working on the pile
since thursday
we're going 24-7 no one is stopping with
149 people still missing including four
canadians
the most difficult moments have come
when families have been brought to the
site
when you're down there and you hear
the sounds you smell the smells
and you see with your own eyes in real
life what it looks like
a lot of things become a lot clearer
just outside the perimeter we met
fernanda figuiardo
on the night of the collapse she
convinced her boyfriend eric dimora to
stay at her house
instead of returning home to his 10th
floor apartment in champlain towers
probably he will arrive at home take a
shower
and die it was a miracle
for families of the missing and for
survivors grief and shock are tinged
with anger
how one building can go down
like that like a bone looks like a bone
the cause is still under investigation
photos obtained by the miami herald show
the deteriorating concrete under the
building's pool
two days before the collapse in april
residents were warned that structural
damage had become significantly worse
since a 2018 inspection
and would require 15 million dollars
worth of repairs
there are at least 115 buildings in the
miami area
approaching their 40-year inspection
cycle i think the big question now is
for those buildings from the 1980s it
are sort of a unique typology there was
like a rush
to miami a rush of development during
that time
development that included the now
collapsed champlain towers
where each day of digging through the
rubble reveals only heartache
when we talk about the three million
pounds of debris that have been removed
it's actually being
hauled away in dump trucks under police
escort they move down these streets in
convoys
they're headed to a warehouse where that
debris can be subjected to forensic
analysis
in hopes of finding out what caused the
collapse donna
so much work to do jackson prosco in
surfside florida thanks
australia goes from covid's success
story to a growing
outbreak coming up why millions of
people are forced into lockdown
some potential good news tonight about
the modern vaccine
it's a very small study and it reveals
the vaccine produced antibodies against
all variants tested including the highly
transmissible delta variant
the data also shows murderner is far
more effective against the delta variant
than the beta variant that's the one
first discovered in south africa
the study was conducted on blood serum
from just eight people one week after
they received the second dose
there's more evidence mixing the oxford
astrazeneca vaccine with the pfizer
biontec vaccine
for the second dose provides greater
protection than two doses of astrazeneca
a study from oxford university where the
astrazeneca vaccine was developed
found there was a much stronger immune
response after mixing doses
two doses of pfizer's mrna vaccine
produced the highest levels
of antibodies in australia more than 20
million people are now
under lockdown to try to stop the spread
of the delta variant there
perth the capital of western australia
is in a four-day lockdown
five million people in the sydney region
are also being told to stay at home for
two weeks
australia's largest city recorded at
least 150 new covent 19
cases brisbane and darwin are also
locking down
australia's vaccine rollout has been
slow less than 4 percent of the
population
is fully vaccinated unvaccinated
travelers planning to leave florida on a
royal caribbean cruise
will need to show proof of health
insurance for covet 19.
the company made the announcement after
four people on two different cruise
ships
tested positive this month in florida
the government blocks companies from
demanding proof of vaccinations so
the company had to use a different
method to ensure
passenger safety ahead the pandemic's
deadly toll on canadians why it could be
far greater
than we realize
you're watching global national
some troubling new insight has emerged
about how canada's death toll from
covid19 might have been
underestimated a new study published by
the royal society of canada
says the actual number of canadians who
died could be much higher than the
official count of more than 26 thousand
it has been widely reported 58 percent
of canada's covid19 deaths
have occurred among older adults in
long-term care facilities
now an in-depth analysis suggests at
least two-thirds of deaths that happened
outside care homes may have been missed
abigail beeman
explains that could have prevented him
from dying
and my baby girl could have her dad
vincenza vono's husband mauro
died of pneumonia and coveted in april
their daughter was just four months old
she says he tried to get an x-ray but
was declined
waking up every day it's just you're
reliving that nightmare that your
husband isn't there and he died
alone sick and it could have been
prevented
vono died at home a new report found
there are many more canadians like him
shocking it really tells the tale of the
fact that we only understand what's at
the tip of the iceberg
the report suggests at least two-thirds
of covet-19
deaths outside of long-term care may
have been missed
using tools including excess deaths
cremation data and antibody tests
researchers found between february and
november of 2020
about 6 000 people 45 and older
died with covid19 undetected if deaths
were missed at the same rate going
forward
the researchers say the total pandemic
death rate could be two times higher
government statistics currently pegs it
to more than 26 thousand
had we had this information in a more
timely way
we may have been able to save many more
lives one explanation coveted symptoms
can present a typically especially in
older people
the authors say reporting on deaths can
fall short in many places in canada
we must have national reporting
of deaths due to any cause within a week
of them happening
we need this across the country canada's
chief public health officer
acknowledged a gap real-time mortality
reporting
alongside the other indicators are
you know really quite critical to
any future responses the report assumes
many of these undetected deaths were
among low-income earners essential
workers or people from racialized
communities
groups already disproportionately
affected perhaps
affected even more abigail beeman global
news
ottawa up next a canadian billionaire
chips in to help protect
rare bc forests
british columbia is known for its beauty
and for the right price
you can buy a piece of it there are
idyllic uninhabited islands for sale not
far from vancouver
protecting these pristine places
requires big money
and now billionaire chip wilson the
founder of lululemon
is stepping in to help robin gill is on
one of the islands
tonight saturnina island in bc's
picturesque gulf islands
is only accessible by boat no one lives
here
at one point it was going to be sold for
1.45
million dollars to anyone wanting to
build a home here there was multiple
offers for much more than the asking
price
and the the vendor agreed to sell it to
us
for less than those offers because
he was interested in seeing it protected
bc parks wanted that too
and to keep it for the public to enjoy
enter a burly benevolent billionaire
lululemon founder chip wilson it's
overwhelming
it's you can almost cry like why
where is this where's this jewel been
hiding and i've never seen it
his 4 million donation will preserve
saturnina
along with west bellinas and a portion
of leskidi
together known as the salish sea islands
along with the extraordinary ecosystems
of animals and plant life that call the
islands home
altogether that money will save 365
acres and to put it in perspective it's
about a third of stanley park
in vancouver and this part of bc is home
to the towering coastal douglas firs
decades of development have reduced the
number of old growth trees and what's
left
is in danger if it's an ecologically
sensitive
piece of land i would opt for nature
always even
students from a local kayak team wanted
to help they did their own fundraiser
collecting five thousand dollars we
decided
that we were going to cut wood for
whatever reason
and you know we weren't using saws it
was all axe work
yeah and we sold the wood yes wilson is
watching for other land that can still
be preserved
100 it's a part of canada relatively few
people have seen
by bringing philanthropy investment and
concern for the environment together
everyone here hopes to protect it so
everyone
can enjoy it robin gill global news
saturnina island
bc that's global
national for this tuesday i'm donna
friesen keeping it in bc tonight's your
canada is
campbell river beautiful shot we'd love
to see your canada please email it
to viewers at globalnational.com thanks
for watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow
take care of yourselves bye-bye